وافقت الحكومه الاسرائيليه على انشاء جهاز
الامني الجديد تحت مسمى الحرس الوطني
سيكون تحت ابره وزير الامن القومي اتمر
بنجفير وقال مكتب نتنياهو ان اللجنه من
جميع الاجهزه الامنيه ستجتمع في غضون 90
يوما لتحديد مهام وصلاحيه الحرس وقد عبر
قائد الشرطه الاسرائيليه والمستشار
القضائيه للحكومه وزع مات المعارضه عن
رفضهم للخطبه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دوافع الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لتشكيل جهاز الامن الجديد رغم
تعدد وتنوع الاجهزه لديها وما طبيعه الجدل
الداخلي حول هذه الخطوه ولماذا تصفه
المعارضه بانه بمثابه ميليشيا خاصه
ببنجفير وهولاه المتطرفين وكيف ستنعكس
سياسه حكومه اليمين المتطرف بانشاء
تشكيلات امنيه جديده على سلوك قوات
الاحتلال وتصعدها المستمر ضد الفلسطينيين
بالاختيالات والاقتحامات والاعتقالات
والى اين ستجر الحلول الامنيه وسياسه
تصعيد الاسرائيلي الاوضاع بالمنطقه في ظل
تهديدات فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه بالرد
على ممارسات الاحتلال وما تشهده الجبهات
الخارجيه من حاله احتقان
[موسيقى]
اذا جهاز امني اخر يوشك على الولاده في
اسرائيل
تلقفوا الجدل الساخن داخل النخب
الاسرائيليه حاكمه ومعارضه ومعارضه امنيه
وقانونيه وزير الامن القومي في حكومه
نتنياهو قال ان الجهاز الجديد سيكون تابعا
لوزارته كاشفا لانه سيكون مكلفا بتعامل مع
ما وصفها بسيناريوهات طارئه والجرائم
القوميه والارهاب خطوه لقيت معارضه حتى
داخل اجهزه الدوله فقد اكد رئيس الشرطه
الاسرائيليه يعقوب شفتاي انه ليس من
الواضح على الاطلاق الدواعي التي تبرر
انشاء جهازا جديد تتداخل صلاحياته ومهامه
مع الاجهزه العامله حاليا في اسرائيل
المستشاره القضائيه للحكومه غالي باراز
نيرا اعربت عن معارضتها لانشاء جهاز الحرس
متحدثه
عن عوائق قانونيه تتعلق بالخطوه المثيره
للجدل زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه يا
ايرلابيد كان اعلى صوتا في انتقاد المشروع
حيث قال ان حكومه نتنياهو وافقت على انشاء
جيش من البلطجيه ومليشيا خاصه
صحيفه يدعونت اكدت من جانبها ان نتنياهو
وافق على انشاء جهاز الحرس بعد موافقه
بنغفير على تعليق ما يوصف بخطه اصلاح
القضاء التي بدورها تلاقي معارضه شديده
وسط تحذيرات من تداعيات هذه الخلافات على
مستقبل دوله اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
عمان اللواء واصفريقات الخبير والمحلل
العسكري والاستراتيجي والفلسطيني وينضم
الينا من الناصره الدكتور محمود يزبك
استاذو الدراسات الشرق اوسطيه في جامعه
حيفا والخبير في الشان الاسرائيلي اهلا
بكما في هذه الحلقه وابدا معك في حيفا
دكتور محمود يزبك
دعنا نطرح في البدايه السؤال الذي يطرحه
العام والخاص داخل وخارج اسرائيل هل هناك
فعلا حاجه
لخلق جهاز امني جديد في اسرائيل
لا طبعا يعني واضح انه الاجابه على هذا
السؤال هو لا يوجد اي حاجه يعني يوجد ما
اجهزه امنيه في اسرائيل تكفي ليس فقط
لدوله اسرائيل بل مجموعه كثيره من الدول
ولكن واقع المنطقه وواقع الحكومه
الاسرائيليه والضعف الذي يعني يبص هنا
ثنياهو في موقعه كرئيس حكومه اجبره يعني
في هذه المرحله لقبول شرط من شروط بنجفير
لدعمه في قضيه توقيف او يعني تجميد
التشريعات القانونيه الحاليه فهذا الدليل
يعني هذا اكبر دليل على حقيقه ما نقوله
منذ ثلاثه اشهر بان هذه الحكومه هي ضعيفه
جدا ورئيس الحكومه يعني غير متزن بقراراته
يعني وهذه يعني هذا وصف جديد لحكومه
نتنياهو نفسه الذي كان يوصف يعني في
الحكومات السابقه بانه كان رئيسا قويا
يعني صاحب سلطه الان يعني وزير مثل بن
جبير الذي يعتبر وزير امن قومي هو شخصيه
سياسيه مهزوزه مهزوزه نفسيا ومدان من قبل
المحاكم الاسرائيليه ب 13 ادانا ومنها
ادانه الارهاب
والتحريض والكراهيه وهذه يعني التهم كبيره
جدا ادانتها المحاكم الاسرائيليه ضد بن
كبير فشخص من هذا النوع هو الذي يسيطر على
مجرى الامور بالحكومه وهو الذي يعني يشرط
ماذا تفعل الحكومه كيف تتصرف يدل دلاله
كبيره جدا بانه لا في حاجه لهذه لهذا
الجهاز الا فقط ارضاء النفسيه المريضه
لوزير الامن الداخلي بن جبير بانه هذه
النفسيه تريد وكانه السيطره على الجماهير
العربيه الفلسطينيه في الداخل وفي المنطقه
المحتله ولكن يعني كل المحللين الامنيين
في اسرائيل يقولوا انه ما لم تستطع ان
تفعله كل هذه الاجهزه الامنيه والمنظومه
الامنيه الاسرائيليه الهائله التي تتعامل
مع الفلسطينيين ان كانوا في الداخل في
اراده 48 او في المناطق المحتله لا يستطيع
اي جهاز جديد ان يعمل شيئا جديدا مما كان
على العكس الجهاز الجديد اذا ما قام هو
طبعا واضح انه سيكون من قوى يعني
يمينيه متصرفه فاشيه سيزيد فقط تازيم
المنطقه وقد يؤدي الى انفجار كبير في
سيكون بها نعم متطوعين المتطوعين نحن
سمعنا انهم بداوا حتى يعملوا في مناطق
معينه في الجنوب في منطقه النكب ولكن
هؤلاء يعني حتى النظامين هل حدد له نطاق
جغرافي للعمل نعم وهو نعم هو نعم يتحدث
الوزير عن اولا يعني اعاده الحوكمه ما هو
يقولها او الحكم لمنطقه النقب العربيه
الفلسطينيه في الجنوب ومنطقه الجليل
ومنطقه الجريل مثل ما تعلمي حضرتك بانه هي
منطقه يعني اكثر سكانها من الفلسطينيين
العرب ولذلك يعني وكانه دوله اسرائيل هو
يريد ان يبث ويقول للمجت لدوله اسرائيل
على الرغم من قوتها غير موجوده على في ارض
الواقع وهو يريد يعني اعاده قوه
واحتلالها من جديد واحتلال منطقه الجليل
من جديد اللي ناخذ راي الاستاذ واصف
عالريقات يعني الاهداف
الميدانيه التي سينصب عليها عمل او سيقوم
بتنفيذها هذا الجهاز الامني الجديد انت
كيف تراه
يعني واضح انه بنجفير يعني سيره الذاتيه
وخلفيه الايديولوجيه وثقافه الكراهيه التي
يحملها يحملها وكما قال ضيفك انه هناك 43
تهمه جنائيه حتى ان نقابه المحامين نقابه
المحامين الصهيونيه لم تقبل به فبالتالي
كما يسمى باسرائيل هو هو الطفل المراهق
الذي يحمل اشاره العار فبالتالي هذا هذا
هو وحسبه وطبعا كلهم من شاكلته من
المستوطنين الذين سيقودون هذا هذه
العصابات التي تذكرنا بعصابات الهجانه
التي ارتكبت المجازر بحق الشعب الفلسطيني
شعارهم شعارهم في هذه المرحله هي يعني
اولا ثقافه كراهيه للمسلمين بشكل عام
ثقافه كراهيه هم الذين يرفعون شعار الموت
للعرب ويرفعون طرد الفلسطينيين بالاشكال
الكافه فبالتالي يعني البؤر المتوتره في
في داخل فلسطين المحتله من قبل المستوطنين
وغلاه المستوطنين يقودها بنجافير اذا
بنجافير الهدف المركزي والهدف الرئيسي في
ذهنه هو توتير المنطقه وتفجير المنطقه
لانه
يشعر بانه ان 800 الف طبعا نحن نقول ان
المجتمع الصهيوني هو سكن عسكريه بكامله
ولكن هناك 800 800 جندي وشرطي مجندين سواء
كانوا عاملين او احتياط هؤلاء من وجهه نظر
بن جفير لم يستطيعوا ان يواجهوا
الفلسطينيين او يطردوا الفلسطينيين
فبالتالي هو يعتقد واهما بانه يستطيع من
خلال المستوطنين الذين سيقودهم ومن خلال
هذا التشكيل العصابي الجديد انه سيفلح في
طرد الفلسطيني الفلسطينيين اقول لك اختي
العزيزه الفلسطينيين لا يهب ولا من جفير
ولا من قياده
نتنياهو المتطرفه هذه حكومه يمين متطرفه
يعني تستحق ان يكون بنجافير على راسها
لانه سيذهب بهم الى الجحيم لكن ماذا لو
فعلا يعني قام بما يهدد به الان من خلال
هذه الدراع وهذا الجهاز الامني الجديد
بتنفيذ عمليات
انتقاميه واعتداءات على بلدات وقرى بداخل
بداخل الفلسطيني
يعني بالتاكيد سيكون هناك مزيدا من الالم
مزيدا من الدماء مزيدا من الدموع ولكن
سيكون هناك مزيد من التضحيات الشعب
الفلسطيني لن يقبل لن يقبل في بنجافير
وامثال بنجافير يعني لم يقبل بعصابات
الهجنه والارجون حينما كان يعني في مرحله
في مرحله الضعف الان الشعب الفلسطيني في
مرحله القوه هناك الان يعني قوه تتشكل
هناك جيل من الشباب الذين يعني راهن
الاسرائيليون على انه سيننسى القضيه
الفلسطينيه وان الكبار سيموتون الكبار
الان يغذون الصغار الذين يحملون السلاح في
مقاومه هذا الاحتلال خيري علقم خيري علقم
لوحده واجه الجندي اسرائيلي توجهوا الى
مخيم جنين حينما حينما يعني استهدفت تسعه
من المستوطنين في القدس بينما الجيش
الاسرائيلي توجه على راس الف جندي من اجل
يعني مخيم ومن اجل اعتقال اثنين من مخيم
جنين وطبعا اغتال بدم بارد ثمان شهداء
فلسطينيين فبالتالي هذه المعادله الان هي
المعادله الفلسطينيه في مواجهه بن جفير بن
جفير الذي يعني اشعل حواره حريقا والذي
يريد الان ذبح القرابين في المسجد الاقصى
من خلال هذه المليشيا من خلال هذه
العصابات انا اعتقد انه يعني سيفجر
المنطقه وان الشعب الفلسطيني قادر على
مواجهته سواء كان في ال 48 او في القدس او
في الضفه الغربيه او في قطاع غزر طيب ما
الذي يجبر دكتور محمود يسبك ما الذي يجبر
نتانياهو على
القبول على قبول مثل هذه الخطوه قبل قليل
قدمت لنا خلفيه شخصيه لبنجفير انه شخصيه
ضعيفه وغير ذلك لكن نتنياهو ما الذي يجبره
على ان يقبل بما يقدم عليه بنكير
في واقع الحال نتنياهو هو رئيس حكومه ضعيف
جدا في هذه المرحله اذا هو يعني حكومته
تتعلق عمير في المرحله هذه التي نعيشها
باصوات بنج فيرو واصوات الاحزاب الفاشيه
والخلفيه لهذا المقترح الذي نراه امام
اعيننا في هذه الايام قبل اسبوع فقط حينما
يعني اراد او اضطر عمليا نتنياهو لتجميد
العمليه التشريعيه
في ضد المحكمه العليا لم يكن امام نتنياهو
الا ان يقبل بالشرط الذي وضعه بالكبيره
وغير ذلك كانت ستسقط الحكومه وهذا الشرط
هو نتحدث عنه الان وهذا هذه المليشيا
العصابات التي نتحدث عنها وقبل نتنياهو
بهذا الشرط بسبب ضعف حكومته وضعفه هو في
الحكومه ولذلك الخلفيه هي ليست انه يعني
في هنالك حاجه لهذه العصابات انما هي فرض
يفرضه من خلال ايديولوجيه يتحدث عنها خلال
المعركه الانتخابيه الاخيره وحتى يعني منذ
ان يعني باشر عمله كعظم الكنيسه خلال
السنتين هو يتحدث طول الوقت على هذا العمل
عن هذا الشيء بانه يجب اقامه مثل هذه
العصابات والمليشيا لانه الفلسطينيين يعني
استطاعوا ان يتمردوا حسب ما يقول ما بين
قوسين اقتباس على دوله اسرائيل وخاصه في
داخل الاراضي ال 48 فهو يريد هذه المليشيا
في البدايه من اجل يعني معالجه قضايا 48
الفلسطينيين في داخل اسرائيل المواطنين في
اسرائيل ولكن هنا الواضح وضوحا تعمل
بالنسبه لكل الفلسطينيين يعني كل
المواطنين فقط قبل يومين في 30 اذار كان
ردا فلسطينيا مدويا لما لقرار بن كبير
يعني لما حاول كثير ان يكررها حينما قال
ان العالم الفلسطيني في اراضي اسرائيل في
منطقه اسرائيل 48 ممنوعا هذا قرار من
الوزير نفسه وقبل يومين في الثلاثين من
الاظافر في يوم الارض في سخنين رفعنا
عشرات الاف الاعلام الفلسطينيه في مظاهره
يوم الارض الاخيره الذكرى 47 ليوم الارض
يعني امتلعت السماء بعلم فلسطين فهل جرا
او يجرؤ بن كبيره او غيره ان يعتدي على
هذا العلم حينما يرفعه شباب بالشعب
الفلسطيني في اراضي ال 48 نحن نتحداه بانه
لن يستطيع لا هو ولا عصاباته ان يفعلوا اي
شيء من اجل نحن ابناء هذه الارض لن نقتلع
من جديد يعني انا اريد ان اقولها من خلال
سيدتي نحن لن نهجر هجرنا في الماضي في
ارادت 48 ونحن اليوم افعلوا ما شئتم ايها
القوى الصهيونيه بنا نحن باكون في ارضنا
متجذرون بها اذا متنا فنموت في ولن نبقى
ان نعيش غير ارضنا في غير وطننا وفي غير
الارض ولذلك يعني كل هذه الخزعبلات التي
يستعملها بنك فييرا هو سينتهي بعد سنه
سنتين انا لا اعرف متى ستحل هذه الحكومه
ولكن شعبنا باقي الى الابد ولا يهمنا لا
شرطه بني كبير ولا عصابات ولذلك يعني هذا
يعني فيه قضيه انه يريد ان يتحدى او انه
يعني يجمل صورتها امام المجتمع الاسرائيلي
اصلهيوني ولكن حتى المجتمع الصهيوني يعرف
بانه هذه الشخصيه المهزوزه التي تسمى بن
جير لا تستطيع ان تفعل شيئا لانه احنا
اتخذنا كشعب قرار بالبقاء في ارضنا
نعمقات يعني في ظل هذا او مع هذا المتغير
الامني الجديد في اسرائيل ماذا يفترض ان
يكون رد الفعل الفلسطيني رد فعل من نفس
النوع كيف ترى ان يفترض ان يكون رد الفعل
الفلسطيني اذا
يعني انا بتقديري يفترض ان يكون هناك وحده
وطنيه ان ننهي الانقسام ان نكون يعني ضمن
استراتيجيه وطنيه واحده ان نقابل امثال بن
جفير ومخططاته الجراميه لانه الشعب
الفلسطيني حقيقه وحدته هي سر قوته
فبالتالي السلاح الوحيد الذي يستقوي به
الفلسطينيين على هذا العدو الغاشم على
راسهم بن جفير وسمووتريش انا بتقديره هي
ان ينهي الانقسام وان يكون هناك وحده
وطنيه وان يكون هناك استراتيجيه لمواجهه
جديده الان الان اصبح كل شيء مكشوف اختي
العزيزه يعني
ما يطرح بن جفير خطير جدا وخطير للغايه
فبالتالي لا يمكن السكوت عليه او الانتظار
حتى يشعل المنطقه فبالتالي هذا هذا ارتكب
حماقات وجرائم في في الماضي ومازال يرتكب
وبالتالي يعني نحن نتوقع ان يصعد ان يصعد
وان يعني يخترع من ذهنه العفن ومن الحقد
والكراهيه المدفونه الموجوده لديه مزيد من
بؤر الاشتعال في المنطقه خاصه في منطقه 48
وهو يعد لذلك
وتحديدا بالقدس لانه طبعا سيدعم
المستوطنين الذين الان يحضرون سيناريوهات
لاقتحام المسجد الاقصى وذبح القرابين
وطبعا هو الذي رفع شعار يعني المسجد
الاقصى
للجميع وليس للمسلمين فبالتالي اذا ما
اراد ان ينفذ هذا هذا الشعار على ارض
الواقع انا بتقدير الفلسطيني هنا مجبر
مجبر على ان يجيش الطفل الفلسطيني قبل
المراه وقبل الشيخ
لحمايه المقدسات والمسجد الاقصى اضافه الى
ما تفضل به ضيفك ان اهلنا في 48 ايضا
جاهزون التصدي لانه ايضا هو يعني من يدعو
من يدعو لتفتيت المجتمع الفلسطيني في داخل
ال 48 لانه في معركه سيف القدس وفي معركه
وحده القدس ووحده الشعب الفلسطيني وخلق
معادلات ردع جديده ثبت لبنجفير وللقياده
الصهيونيه بان هذا الشعب الفلسطيني اذا ما
توحد سيستطيع سيستطيع مواجهه كل المخططات
الصهيونيه وعلى راسها مخططات نتنياهو بن
جفير فبالتالي نحن امام يعني ميليشيات
وعصابات جديده يقودها واحد احمق يقودها
واحد يعني مجرم يعني امتداد لعصابه الكاخ
ويحمل عقيده يعني عقيده قتاليه عقيده
جابوتينسكي القوه الفولاذيه يعني ما لم
يحقق بالقوه يحقق بمزيد من القوه ما لم
يحقق بالقتل يحقق بمزيد من القتل ومزيد من
الدماء اذا امام هذا هذا التطرف وهذا
الفهم يجب ان يكون هناك موقف فلسطيني يعني
قادر على ردع امثال بنجافير طيب على ذكر
الموقف فلسطيني ايضا بالنسبه لي وهنا اعود
الى الدكتور محمد محمود ايضا بالنسبه
للفلسطينيين في الداخل الاوراق التي يمكن
ان تستخدم في الداخل الفلسطيني
للصمود كما قال استاذ واصف عريقات في وجه
هذه المخططات ماذا بالامكان فعله بالنسبه
للفلسطنين في الداخل
يعني نحن في الداخل يعني مجتمع انا اعتقد
يعني متوحد في
موقفه تجاه الحكومه الاسرائيليه واتجاه بن
جير يعني ما في عنا خلافات في الداخل
باتجاه هذا القضيه بمعنى انه يعني سيكون
وردودنا مثلما يعني انا اتحدث من خلال
الارض من خلال الناس يعني وقضيه يوم الارض
الاخير في 30 اذار كانت حقيقه ردا يعني
واقعيا كيف يكون الرد الحقيقي والطبيعي
لمجتمع يريد الحياه نحن نريد الحياه ولذلك
حينما رايته الاعلام ترفع بايدي الشباب
والشابات الفلسطينيات اعمار 20 25 30
عشرات الاعلام الفلسطينيه وادي هويتنا
نقولها بكل اعتزاز وفخر على الرغم من
وجودنا كمواطنين نحن ابناء شعبه فلسطين
اينما كان نعيش في ارضنا ولذلك ما يمثلنا
هو علمنا وعلمنا الذي يمثلنا ولا العالم
الفلسطيني هذا كان رد حقيقي
اقليمي او دولي يمكن التعويل عليه نعم
استاذ محمود هذا رد بالنسبه للداخل ولكن
ماذا يعني الموقف الاقليمي والدولي
باختصار لو سمحت بالنسبه للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه مثلا نعم
احنا يعني اولا اتفق مع ضيفك الاستاذ
العريقات بانه اولا يجب ان يكون رد
فلسطيني والرد الفلسطيني الذي نتمناه
ونرجوه من قيادتنا الفلسطينيه في رام الله
وفي غزه عنه حقيقه ننهي هذا الانقسام
لنستطيع ان نخطو خطوات مدروسه امام هذه
المخاطر التي نعيشها اثنين في هنالك
التغيرات واضحه في الشرق الاوسط تغيرت
الايجابيه في الشرق الاوسط من ناحيه
العلاقات ما بين الدول وانهاء الخلافات
ولكن كل هذا من اجل الضغط بالنهايه على
العالم ونحن في لدينا مؤسسات المجتمع
المدني في داخل فلسطين التي تسعى من اجل
الضغط على متخذ القرار في العالم في
اوروبا وامريكا ليفهم طبيعه الواقعه في
اسرائيل اكثر من اي وقت شكرا واعتذر لاني
انتهى وقت البرنامج شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور
محمود
حيفا والخبير في شان الاسرائيلي شكرا لك
وايضا نشكر ضيفنا الاستاذ واصفات من
عمان شكرا لكما
والى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج مهور
الخبر لكم منا اطيب المنى والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]